greetings everyone this is rob sanders
and thank you for joining me
today we're going to talk about seo
tools let's get started
so if you're doing seo and you're doing
on-page and off-page
seo for an organization or website
you're going to need some tools to help
you so you can't go at it alone you
can't do anything manually
you have to lean on tools to help you
work more efficiently
help you gain an advantage and so if
you're doing seo you're going to need
tools for keyword research
you're going to need tools to help you
with the technical aspects related to
seo
you're going to have to use some tools
for off-page seo including
backlink monitoring and analysis and
then there's tools for
helping you track where your keywords
and pages rank so there's tools for
every element of seo and today we're
going to take a look at
some of the best tools out there on the
market to help you do your job better so
let's start with the keyword research
so with keyword research tools you can
do your job a lot more efficiently
finding the right relevant keywords i
mean that's really key to seo is finding
keywords that are relevant to your
business
product or service that you want to rank
for so you want to be able to choose
keywords with high search volume and low
competition so where do you get those
numbers you get those from
certain tools you also want to get
forecasts for certain targeted keywords
you want to be able to generate a list
of latent semantic
indexing type keywords or keywords close
to the keyword you're trying to target
you want to be able to select primary
and second
keywords wisely so having a list of
keywords or certain data points will
help you do that and you want to be able
to identify the keywords that your
competitors are also ranking for
so good keyword research tool will help
you do all of those things
so what are some of the the tools out
there well look no further than some of
the free ones that google offers like
google trends
so google trends is a good tool that you
can lean on if so if we look at google
trends
all you need to do is trends.google.com
you could type in a keyword
i can look at the volume or interest of
that keyword
over time here i'm looking at football
versus american football
and i could see how it's trending then i
could see
you know how it trends in specific
regions of say the united states as my
market
i can also look at other related queries
similar to football or american football
and so
google trends is a good tool helps you
look at the volume
helps you look at what specific regions
help you look at other keywords
you know if you want you can simply just
do a keyword search or you can actually
just see what's trending just by looking
at the latest stories and insights
so we could see international women's
day you know started to pick up steam
it's picking up more steam etc so it's
certain
keywords that tend to trend well and you
can pick up on what those keywords are
using google trends now you could also
use another google tool called google
keyword planner the only difference is
this one's paid
you need a google ads account so if we
go into
google ads hey you'll need to go to
tools and you'll need a keyword planner
but when you're in keyword planner you
can find new keywords
so if i type in for example you know
online marketing
and click get started what the keyword
tool is going to do
is give me the data that i need to do
appropriate keyword research
it's going to give me my keyword and
similar keywords it's going to give me
the average monthly volume
and the great thing here is i can
actually see the trend for that keyword
over time just by clicking on this
little bar graph so for digital
marketing i could see what the trend is
over time
i can see what the competition is i
could see you know
if i'm going to bid on this keyword i
could see what the bidding range is
so more important i could see the volume
and i can see the competition here's my
volume for this keyword
over the last 12 months on average and
here's my competition so google's
keyword planner
gives you the necessary information you
need to choose relevant keywords wisely
now there are other tools out there that
are paid
that help you look for relevant keywords
like semrush
or keyword finder that's a freemium tool
so there are plenty
of tools available to you you know
another tool i use that's not listed
here is moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like
online marketing for example okay so
what
moz is going to do is going to give me
some volume it's going to give me some
other keyword suggestions okay it's
going to tell me how difficult that
keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword
so it gives me again all the relative
information i need including competitive
information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools
moz is freemium some are paid some are
free there's plenty of tools out there
but these are the ones i would recommend
for keyword research now let's turn our
attention to
technical seo so for technical seo
you're going to need to use some tools
there's no getting around that because
you want to be able to monitor
how your website is performing i mean is
it loading slow
for example does it have a lot of issues
with the website in terms
of server-side rendering for example or
server response time what about 4-4s and
redirects
so you want to be able to gather a lot
of the technical information
that could aid or prohibit your site
from ranking so
you want to be able to also you know
look at what the bots are saying and how
they're
viewing your website so if google goes
to crawl your site are they experiencing
you know a slow server response time or
they experiencing pages not found
you also want to see if you have a site
map you know what's the site map
are these bots crawling your site or
getting the pages from a sitemap
again you want to be able to lean on
some of these tools to help you
fix errors that you may encounter like
meta tags or
four fours or canonicals so you need a
good
tool to help you manage all that and so
i'm gonna go back to maz starting out so
if we go back to maz maz
is a good tool it's an all-in-one it's a
great seo platform
so if i go to moz and i log into an
account i can just go to sitecrawl
and so what moz is going to do it's
going to give me a lot of information
about
how moz's bot is seeing my site okay so
if i go
to the cycle i can look at all the
particular critical
issues that have experienced so i could
see four or four errors okay reiterates
related to that
i could see meta descriptions missing
meta descriptions
duplicate content so there's a lot of
different issues that
moz is detecting for this particular
site and the great thing about moz
and this is why i use moz is my seo
platform i don't work for moz i've just
used them a long time
is if you do have issues then they give
you ways to fix it the how to fix it
section so
if i see missing description here if i
just click on review
i can get a more in-depth analysis as to
what the issues are here
but i can also click on the why and how
to fix okay and they're going to give
you some information about how this is
impacting seo
and what you could do to fix the issue
they lay out the issues pretty
prominently here you can see for all the
metadata issues i have i have you know
142
total metadata issues i have 10 title
tag
two longs i have 122 missing meta
descriptions
so they lay it out nicely here up the
top so you can kind of get a sense
of what to work on and again they
prioritize it based on
the severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example i just looked at metadata
issues you can see
if i click on content issues i have some
duplicate content that moz is
recognizing
or missing or valid h tags so maz does a
really really great job
laying on all the issues out for you to
recognize
okay there's another tool that i like to
use called screaming frog
it's a pay tool so if we go look here
great thing i like about
a screaming frog it will crawl your
sight and
it will give you some list of issues
just like moz does
of you know what it sees in your site is
it experiencing four or fours
broken links are there any redirects
it's picking up duplicate content
site maps you know they're javascript
issues
how is it see the site architecture so
it really does
take a deep look at everything that
could impact your website from ranking
okay there are other tools out there
like
you know deep crawl or woo rank they're
both paid
and so pay tools are really great as
well it just depends on
you know your pricing structure what
your budget is but
really when it comes to all these tools
they all more or less overlap and do the
same thing you
just need to rely on one of them to make
sure that
you're able to see what the issues are
now there's nothing wrong with using two
of them just as a second reference point
to see if both are picking up the same
issue and of course i like to use
search console i always like to lean on
google search console because that is
the source
so search console will also you know
give you some feedback on how
google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here
so you can also you know use search
console to upload a sitemap so
that's a key to seo you want google to
be able to find
your web pages quickly so you can simply
just signify to google where your site
map is located
so the search console does a lot more
gives you some html improvements gives
you some backlinking
uh and then the process of updating this
search console user interface so there's
a new user interface that you can use
with google search console
the great thing is it's free and it has
everything you need to know about
your website and how it's affected by
seo
organic search the only thing you have
to do with search console is verify the
site but once you verify it it has all
the relevant information you need so
let's talk about
backlink monitoring and analysis okay so
this is related to off-page seo so
you're going to need a good tool to help
you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from
external sites pointing to your site and
you need to keep
an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good or relevant sites or anything
in between
so you need to really be able to analyze
what the
good links are and what the bad links
are pointing to your website you want to
identify and disavow poor backlinks
okay so you want to be able to recognize
which sites are linking to yours that's
actually hurting you from an seo
standpoint
and you want to be able to do something
about that okay you want to measure
citation flow and trust flow you want to
check the ratio of link distribution
in terms of is it internal or external
or
you know what kind of sites are linking
to my site are they you know social
related
are they pure content related and then
you want to be able to track the number
of do follow and no
follow links you know how many links
pointing to our site
are actually telling google and other
bots not to follow the link or how many
are
actually allowing the bots to follow
that link if a bot follows a link it's
going to
pass what we call link choose so you're
going to get credit for the backlink if
it's a no follower you're not going to
get credit for the backlink and we want
to be able to measure that and so we
want to have tools that will help us do
that so
what are some of those tools well hrefs
is a good tool it's a pain tool
majestic is a freemium tool moz again
moz is the tool i use sem rush and then
again i gotta mention google search
console so let's take a look at some of
these tools
in terms of backlink monitoring and
analysis so let's start with google
search console again it's free
you just have to verify your site and so
if i go to google search console
i can look at links and i can see what
external links
i have pointing to my site okay so i
could see
i have 17 000 in this example pointing
to the home page of this particular site
okay so if i click on that i can see
all the the top sites pointing to
my home page now from an off page seo
perspective do you want
every backlink or external link pointing
to your homepage
no so you want links pointing to
internal pages so you want to be able to
measure that
so i can see what the top linking sites
are and i can also see what the anchor
text is
so do i want my anchor text always to be
my brand name
no i want it to be you know keyword
we're trying to target
search console also gives you some
internal links okay what are the top
link pages for internal links so from an
seo perspective you always want to have
a nice balance of internal linking
so this report helps you understand what
pages are getting links and are the
links evenly spread so
this is google search console this is
the links report this is totally free
this is provided by google all you have
to do is verify your site
now if we go over to moz we type in a
domain any domain so i just typed in
simply
learn okay moz has some metrics that are
important to off page seo including
domain authority so the higher your
domain authority the better off you are
and so what helps a domain authority
grow is
how many quality links are pointing to
that domain and so here we could see
over
500 linking domains to simply learn so
what's important is
we just don't want any site we want
quality
relevant sites pointing okay so we could
see how many total inbound links
and then how many ranking keywords we
have okay so here
moz is going to give me kind of an idea
of what my domain authority has been
over time
they're going to tell me the top
followed links to this site so they can
tell me you know what are those
links pointing to my site and what's the
page authority
of those sites okay here i can get a
nice graphical breakdown of the linking
domains by domain authority
so you want pages with high domain
authority pointing to your site
so here i can see 69 linking domains
between 91 and 100 so that's really good
we want
high relevant domains linking to our
site so just like
search console i can see the top anchor
text being used
okay and i can see the top pages that
have
you know good page authority on the site
i could see following versus nofollow
on internal and external links so this
is just the overview so moz really
really does break down for you you know
what those pages and linking domains are
so if i just click on linking domains
now i could get a detailed look for my
home page
what domains are pointing to our domain
so i could see microsoft.com has a
domain authority of 100
youtube 99. and so not only does moz
provide you
with the domains it also provides you
with your domain authority score
and spam score so you want to keep an
eye on any particular site that has a
high spam score so
having a site with a high spam score and
a low domain authority
will hurt your domain and page authority
for that page
so moz does a great job of breaking it
out and this is for any page it doesn't
necessarily have to be the home page
okay if i take a look look at another
example here
majestic so majestic again i can use a
free version of the tool
they have their own metrics citation
flow trust flow
so when they say trust flow what's the
link quality all about okay
citation flow what's the link volume and
they can get an idea
of how many external backlinks are
pointing to the site
and what's the trend on that referring
domains
so majestic does a really good job again
some of the
same metrics that we could see here
except they go into detail about
languages as well
so this is majestic and you got search
console you got a lot of other tools and
then i'm going to just revert
back to moz because you want to be able
to compare
link profiles if you're in a competitive
space and you're doing off-page seo
you know moz will help you compare how
your site
stands against maybe another competitive
side or relevant site so
just doing this analysis i can compare
my domain authority spam score
how many total links you know how many
external follow links or external no
follow links
a breakdown of linking domains so it
does a nice
job of comparing one site versus another
that's going back to moz
and that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that i
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright edge
that will also help you compare linking
profiles so at the end of the day if
you're doing
off-page seo you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours
are they quality sites are they spammy
what anchor text are they using are they
no follow
are they do follow you know are they top
domains
how do you compare against your
competitors i mean all these metrics are
related to off-page seo so you want a
good tool
that's going to help you measure this
okay so let's talk about rank tracking
so when we do keyword research we're
looking for relevant keywords we find
our relevant keywords we assign
primary and secondary keywords to pages
we optimize those pages
we do off-page seo we're doing all this
work for seo okay
we want to be able to measure the fruits
of our labor we want to be able to
measure
how we perform for on and off page seo
for the keywords we covet
and the pages they're related to and so
that's where rank tracking comes into
play so we want to be able to track
our website's ranking and not just our
website all the pages we've
optimized we want to be able to measure
our click-through rates and impressions
we want to be able to track the ranking
for both desktop
and mobile for specific locations and we
want to identify
top performing gaining and losing
keywords so
in other words we want to look at trends
is the key word ranking
is it going up and ranking is it going
down and rank and if it's going down in
ranking
then you need to take action so you need
a tool
a good tool for rank tracking so we can
look no further
than again google search console it's
free it's right from the source so let's
take a look at
what google search console has to offer
in terms of rank tracking so
if i go to google search console and i
put in
a url what it's going to do is it's
going to give me
and this is the search queries report
it's going to give me what queries
people have used to actually type into
google.com
and it's going to be able to tell me how
many times my pages
show pages showed up for that query it
could be more than one page
that's an impression and if i did
receive an impression
meaning did my page show up in the
organic listing
then did i get a click as a result and
so in this case if i got 68 impressions
and 10 clicks for
keywords somebody typed in that's a 14.7
click-through rate and so what search
console will also do is say hey look for
that particular keyword you appeared on
average
in position 4.1 so it gives you really
good insight as to you know what people
are typing
in and how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by pages
it breaks it down by country breaks it
down by device
so i could see you know mobile i've had
899 impressions
over the last three months on mobile and
i received 33 clicks as a result
my average position on mobile was 2.6 so
search console does a really good job
again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keyword somebody's using
on google search as a query and how many
impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks
click the rate and then average position
so in theory
the higher you are positioned on google
the more clicks you're going to receive
so if i'm not positioned properly for
keyword
let's say say page 2 then i'm probably
not going to receive as many
clicks as i would like so that's search
console there are other tools
out there like hrefs again does a good
job of tracking amz
tracker we look at winter so there's
some good tools out there i'm just going
to show you another one again i'm going
to go back to
moz for example so moz has
a tool called so if i go back into the
account
so moz has a rankings tool that you can
look at
to see where your keywords are ranking
so if you've already
chosen keywords and optimize pages for
those keywords then you want to be able
to load those keywords into moz
and so moz allows you to do that and so
what moz does
they do a crawl once a week and they'll
be able to tell you where you rank for
all your keywords
are we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
rank between positions one and three
eleven through twenty four through ten
twenty one through fifty
so we'll be able to see where our
keywords rank and so it gives you a
breakdown here
of nationally in the united states where
this keyword is ranked and
if it's moved up or down and for what
url is it ranked for
and so you can label so the keywords and
and this is what you want to look for in
a good tool you want to be able to
organize your keywords and label them so
for all our branded keywords we want to
be able to label them branded because
ideally you don't want to optimize for
your brand keywords so maybe we want to
exclude our brand keywords and look at
our non-brand keywords in terms of
ranking and
so you can certainly add locations and
look at specific locations the whole
idea
between a good ranking tool is to be
able to measure
you know if a keyword is trending up or
down okay so
i can simply look at a particular
keyword and i can see the trend of that
keyword and then you know if a keyword
is not ranking
then we want to wonder why it's not
ranking well is it difficult
is it not ranking because of its
difficulty or
can we do a better job of optimizing for
that keyword and so
moz also has a page optimization tool so
if you're not ranking for keyword
you can flip over the page optimization
tool then
put in the keyword put in the url and
mazda give you some idea as to what you
can further do to optimize the page okay
so that's moz you know this is hrefs
so you can see ahrefs does the same
thing they provide you some visibility
average position how much traffic you
know where you're ranking in terms of
positions one
through three four through 10 11 through
50.
and so you want to be able to get a
sense of
where my track keywords are trending are
they training up are they trending down
and the whole idea again beyond ranking
tools if you're trending down you want
to be able to
address why it's trending now so you
want to start with on-page seo
can we do a better job of optimizing or
off page
does that page need more backlinks so
that's why you need a backlink tool to
support your ranking
and ahrefs does offer up some competitor
information as well so you can see how
your competitors are performing
so these are some good examples of
ranking tools that you can take
advantage of now there are also a few
important seo tools that can be helpful
in different ways for example
if you're doing video so there are some
tools to help you
measure how you're performing via video
for example
vid iq so let's take a look at vid iq so
if i load in say video in youtube
in this example how to rank youtube
videos i have
a vid iq extension loaded into my
browser in chrome
and so now i can get a good eye sense of
how many views
the duration the engagement rate the
like ratio
how many people shared it on reddit but
further i can look at how the video was
optimized so
they're telling me the title's too long
here maybe shorten it up but we have
tags we have descriptions we have cards
we have end screens it's been shared on
facebook and hasn't been shared on
twitter
okay it is public we do have pinned
comments and we do have hearted comments
and so this gives me an idea of how
we did in terms of optimizing this
particular video
okay so if we wanted to tweak it we
could tweak the title tag make it a
little bit shorter to help it
rank better on youtube so you want to be
able to use a tool like this because if
you have videos
then you want those videos to rank and
so you can certainly watch this video on
how to rank your youtube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid iq
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because your youtube
it is a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking
why are you not ranking now for content
optimization
there are tools you can use like seo
site checkup
or site analyzer are some good tools
if you already have moz as an example
just going back to moz
as you already know i use moz a lot so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content
how your optimize your content so it's
going to give me some good feedback on
you know is your page title meta
description are they in line okay so
it's going to give you some
good feedback on that you also have
again i have to
allude to search console you can always
look at
a particular page and search console see
if it has any errors as well so is it
duplicated
meta description is it a duplicated
title tag
is it any pages missing title tags or
meta descriptions so when it comes to
content you can look at search console
you can lean on moz
or you can lean on some of these other
paid versions like
site analyzer when it comes to traffic
and metrics
look no further than google analytics
there is a free version of google
analytics as well as a paid version so
if i go into google analytics
it's going to tell me all of my website
behavior okay who's coming to my site
how they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and
are they achieving the goals i set out
for them to achieve
via conversions and so you want to look
at first in google analytics how much
traffic you're getting
so if i go to google analytics if i go
to acquisition
all traffic channels i should be able to
see how much traffic
organic search is driving over a period
of time
so i could see how many users how many
sessions then if i click on landing
pages i could see what landing page
they went to so i could see the home
page over a particular time
had over a thousand sessions i can also
see engagement from
organic search are they bouncing how
many pages
are they looking at in this session
after they landed on
a particular page are they staying on
the site a long time what's their
duration or
are they achieving any goals so
analytics will provide me all that
information
about how organic search as a channel is
performing the other thing about google
analytics i like and that goes back to
the technical aspect of seo
and that site speed so if you go to
behavior and you go to site speed
overview
you'll be able to see how my pages are
loading what's the average load time
so they'll break it down for you by
browser by country and by specific page
so if i look at page timings
i'll be able to see what page is loading
slow what page is loading quick compared
to site average
and so the great thing about analytics
is if i have a page that's loading slow
compared to site average they'll
actually provide me with some
suggestions
so if i go to site speed and speed
suggestions
what they're going to do is they're
going to have a link in the report
that's going to
allow me to click on it and i'm going to
be able to see what suggestions they can
provide so
when this report loads i'll be able to
see what the speed suggestions are
for my pages so here i could see the
page
i could see what the average load time
is of that page so for example
this particular page is loading at six
seconds ideally we want to have you know
three seconds
or under maximum so if i just click on
this link here they're giving me
six page speed suggestions so if i click
on that i'm gonna go to another google
tool called
page speed insights and then page speed
insights is going to run for both mobile
and desktop
for this particular page and then this
pagespeed insights report
is going to give me feedback as to what
i need to do
to speed up the load time of that page
so here you can see for desktop and
mobile
they're going to give me some
suggestions and opportunities so reduce
the server response time
properly size images serve images in
next gen formats
so all these will shave off time off my
page load time and so that's what's
going to help me speed up the page load
and that's page being insights you can
get to
from the speed suggestions report and
analytics
so in theory the higher page load time
your chances
of ranking on google organic search
diminish
so google wants pages that have very
low page load time that load quickly so
google analytics is great tool for
speed suggestions it's a great tool for
finding out what the traffic is doing on
your site
how they're engaging and are they
achieving goals now there are other
tools out there from an organic
perspective
like keyword it that's a good keyword
research tool for reddit so if you go to
keyword it you'll be able to
see from a reddit perspective what
keywords are driving volume
these are just the results but you can
put any keyword in there and get the
results of that keyword
so thank you for paying attention we
hope some of these tools were useful for
you
if you have any other suggestions on any
tools we didn't mention
in this video then please feel free to
add them to the comment section below
this video
we look forward to getting your comments
and we'll respond accordingly
thank you again and if you have any more
information or need any more information
please visit simplylearn.com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here